alright so dr. jazz a topic title of his
talk is disease mechanisms underlying
neurodegeneration caused by RNA
metabolism abnormalities thank you so at
at first I would like to send either the
McGovern Institute at MIT side and the
organizer to invite us here and
community communicate each other and
present my current work here so I just
recruited by chinua University and about
a year so today my talk is majorly focus
on some work we are going to work on so
so recently there are multiple evidence
suggests that an irony dysfunction of
RNA processing may play a key role in
many neurodegenerative diseases for
example the SMN one molecule that
involving biogenesis of the pre mi
slicing building block has been involved
in has caused the spinal spinal muscular
atrophy and the other evidence from the
dysfunction of RNA binding proteins such
as the IG h mu binding protein we know
that they say that the molecule may have
a function on RNA or DNA helicase and
the other females was tdp-43 and
originally identified by a virgin E&E
and john cho cho Trojanowski group and
the food they involving the mutation has
been found in familiar and sporadic AOS
and f
be patient and the other evidence from
the repeat ding a ding a repeat insert
into the non-coding region in some gene
that the function is not that clear and
that people believe is a general
function so the question I think remain
in the few days why the dysfunction of
RNA processing cause neurodegeneration
so my postal work somehow also
contribute to the to the to the evidence
so we use forward genetics approach to
study neurodegeneration mechanism so in
other words is a phenotype driven
approach so we started with some mutant
mice with neuro degeneration and for
example you see here the seven months
animal in the cerebellum region the
neuron is gone compared to the Y type
and after we find we we we characterize
we identify in the mutant animal wee
folk further identify the mutant gene oh
the the modifier that can enhance all
inhabit enhance or suppress the
pathogenic pathway so this kind of work
will Tippin our understanding of disease
mechanism because if for I can model
disease or Lana memory like dr. John
said so our mouse because Moses is is
memo and their have like more than 90
there's Jing have more than ninety
percent similarity to human human genes
so this finding will help us to deepen
our understanding of what is this
mechanism
so one particular case I today I'm going
to share with you is one like mutant
demise this is generated from am EMS
induced the mutagenesis and the demise
have a particular neurodegeneration in
the cerebellum so majorly is the
granular on so in four months the
homozygous mutant the most of the
cerebellum granular on is gone compared
to the white hypothermic and we also
found the neuron degeneration in the
other brain region including hippocampal
cortex and the spinal cord so the nature
of neural degeneration is clear kospi
street dependent airport with apoptosis
so that I I believe you can appreciate
that by the cusp III standing and
eternal standing so the next question we
want to ask is what the mutation what
the gene dysfunction cause that
phenotype so using the classical mouse
mapping we narrow the built in the
interval to true mit marker and its
contain 10 and protein coding gene and
every sequence everyone and we didn't
find anything polymorphism between the
white hub and mutant the other feature
in our in our interval is there are five
non-coding RNA like like cluster are a
class during our interval so one of them
I lead point out just one of them have
a5 we do credit division so what is this
non-coding RNA so this long cooling our
wave RNA record is you too small nuclear
small nuclear RNA that is the basic
component of prema prema is splicing so
the only splicing can be
can be can be a separate to two steps
why is the assemble face so at that at
that moment so the the other you reading
reach us snr mps so here is the axon
exon 1 and action true in between is the
interference sequence so the axon is the
protein coding and sequence so during
the splicing the interference sequence
that we also called intron will be
surprised so the at the Assembly of face
the you two and you one you want
recognized responsible for recognize the
Phi prime splicing side and you too will
be spearing recognize the branch points
I'd in the intro and the adenosine is
the key a nucleotide the hydroxyl group
will attack the Phi prime surprising
side so the you too hope the branch side
close to the five prime splicing side
and the full view the force the
catalytic reaction so where is our
mutation so actually the five declared
hide is very close to the u2 and brunch
sided duplex the you to sequence is
recognized the brunch side in the intro
of a transcript so the five Luke retired
why two of them is in the branch side
recognition sequence and the other three
is in the in between two domains one is
the brunch side you to do duplex and one
is the you to you six Alex won a the u6
is in in green and it is another you
reading rich snrna in what we in prayer
my splicing so one question puzzles a
lot is why you too is a basal component
that cause a specific neural neuron
neurodegeneration so when we check the
expression profile of this mutant
and we've found so here I want to point
out these aussies rnase protection lousy
no matter how we did it at but here is
the white hype form so that means so the
you to have multiple copies because it's
a hot skipping dream and have the
essential function so in our intro or at
least hire five copies so in the mutant
the homozygous mutant there are white
hype but here is the is the mutant the
phone so the mutant the form actually is
very high in the cerebellum that is the
major Lee affected brain region compared
to the code tags and spinal cord and the
other other non-neuronal regions and we
also today because the time limitation
they also showed that this mutant you to
actually is a temple temporally
regulated that means after post the
little 30 days the mutiny you too is
upregulated in the cerebellum so that's
the question we would like to ask is why
how this mutiny you to affect splicing
so actually at the beginning we detailed
we checked rechecked a lot of splicing
events but we didn't find any major
defect then we think maybe some highly
regulated splicing splicing events like
alternative splicing may be affected so
we go back to find the 20 do not know
alternative splicing events and we check
it and at this time 10 out of 20 is it's
majorly affected so here I just to show
you one case so this like street prime
exon intron is from the one that you're
no gene called l1 camp so the income 27
actually is
small interim it actually is the
alternative surprise the intro so why we
see that because in the white hype the
intro is 310 no matter what time point P
20p 30 and the p40 the interim 27 is 310
but intron 28 is constituted a spliced
will ever see intron 28 signal but in
this mutant after p30 as i mentioned
before this mutant is upregulated after
after posted later 30 days and this
intron great engine is dramatically is
become the major phone compared to the
this splice the phone and so so and we
also check the interim 2728 the
constitutive splicing events we didn't
see any difference between why type and
mutant so these data suggest that this
particular you to mutation affect some
type of alternative splicing but not
constitutive splicing so after that we
want to globally check the splicing
defect in this particular mutant in
predicting this particular mutant in the
cerebellum so this is the so we find
using the RNA are a sick tater next
generation secret sequence hi super
sequence we found many alternative
splicing event change but today but here
i want to emphasize though I've want to
draw draw your attention is the interim
retention humans so every dots should
here is the intron retention you once
the Y X is the interim retention
intensity so is the log 10 value that
means to is mean to 100 folders increase
so these events in the mutant the
cerebellum there
our 4,000 retaining events in the mutant
but in the white house there are only
like 300 the events that has significant
retained in the Y type cerebellum and so
that the x show so we also distribute
this event by there's internets and very
surprisingly we found that the income
retention events almost half of them are
small entrance so that means this event
is susceptible to this particular mutant
built in the particular you to mutation
so we believe that our data like porn
provided that the vanity of evidence
that suggests that the dysfunction of
RNA processing may play a key role in
the etiology of neurodegeneration
together with the other fundings the
other findings so this work is also very
important for us because it's provide an
ideal model to study how the RNA
metabolism cause neurodegeneration so
back to the disease pathogenic pathway
so in general the mutant disease mutant
we are through some pathogenic pathways
such as here I i simplified ABC gene
pathway Cascades then cause the disease
but in our human population so someone
is sensitive to some disease but someone
a lot so there are some like in that
genetic variants or modifiers that can
influence or enhance or suppress the
pathway then will affect the disease
onset and development so that is also
true in the inbred strain
so the original I the original NM 291
mutation actually is a p6 background but
when we cross it to the other string and
we found this dream actually is a bob c
string can largely attenuate the disease
many men is fat man Yousef manifestation
so suggest there is a dominant modifier
that can attenuate the disease so to
identify this modifier will help us to
understand how and why the RNA
metabolism abnormality resulting
neurodegeneration and we believe so the
other dress strategy we want to do is if
some mouse model camp can model that the
disease so whether we can use ian you
based mutagenesis increase the genetic
variance in the mall mouse model then we
can define or identify the modifier that
can accelerate all suppress the disease
development that will help us to
understand that is this mechanism but
when we back to check the mouse model
that model the neuro degeneration caused
the RNA metabolism we are very
frustrated so many models they are
transgenic they are random insert into
the genome and have multiple copies in
the genome for example tdp-43 so right
now there are transgenic models
available but we know that why type even
you overexpress why type tdb4 this year
three also have the neurological
neurodegenerative degenerative phenotype
so the other one of the
one of the rna-binding protein Joe a lot
of our attention is igho binding protein
too because this this mutation is a
recessive mutation actually is a
loss-of-function mutation and it is
cause type 1 spinal muscular atrophy
with muscle weakness and motor
dysfunction and patient have this
mutation often died after birth because
of the respiratory failure so why we we
are we interested in this molecule so
here is the structure of this molecule
so it has the RNA DNA helicase domain
and one like our single one way
recognition sequence and a protein
interaction secret domain and here
showed written by now there are more
than 60 mutations human mutations has
been identified so here showed some of
the mutation in these jeans so luckily
we have a mouse mutation also we have
mouths meditation so the mouse mutation
here showed at this position years of
splicing variants so this rising
warrants cause the splicing jumping to
the interim region then cause the
molecule in the in the animal only
twenty percent of the full dance
molecule is left so this particular
mouse mutation have very similar
phenotype as human patient so the this
mouse mutant also a recessive mutation
and is have the motor neuron
degeneration and a died very early after
birth so this mouse model could be a
very nice model for us to screen the
genetics modifier that can attenuate
okay attenuator or rescue the phenotype
our strategy is use this mutant demise
and use Ian you induced mutagenesis to
scream any dominant modifier that can
rescue or attenuate the disease
manifestation so hopefully our screening
will help us to to to identify lower
gene that can help us understanding
disease mechanism caused by a docile
function of IG H mu binding protein too
so I would like to use this slides to
summarize our research pipeline so we
use for genetics to study
neurodegeneration majorly that caused by
RNA metabolism abnormalities and we also
want to construct some reliable models
that can model the neural degeneration
caused by RNA processing abnormalities
by using recently developed telling all
crisper technologies this work is this
work is is walking in my my current lab
so I would like to end my talk with my
acknowledgements lies so dr. Susan acma
is my postal mentor and John moon from
Stanford help us to analyze
next-generation sequence and i would
like to thnkx constructive discussion
from our colleagues both from beijing
McGovern Institute and Ching hua
becoming Institute and our animal
facility and dr. jin zhang xi and the
boats on help on the talent and crisper
technology and my lab member in the
ching hua university thank you very much
thank you very much wonderful talk one
quick question is that you use the RNA
the metabolic you know approach to study
is it only restrict to the show rebello
serve Allah regeneration a determination
does it also apply to the cortex oh yeah
so August on the SMA beyond the cervelo
instead of the you know the safe and
hulu some other gyro in the context so
actually the as i mentioned so this
particular you to mutation is highly
expressed in the cerebellum but we also
see the phenotype in the hippocampal and
the code has and the spinal cord but
much less that means the dosage is play
a very important role if we can toss
this mutation in the spinal cord we is
back the we will see motor neuron
degeneration one last quick ring you
said have you try to expose the system
to weigh in mu you know this speculation
first line iconic information model
against the background and context and
to see how did RNA met a person will
change accordingly yes it's a is
something we are thinking but we haven't
done yet yeah so um I like your
suggestion that this could be that many
of these neurodegenerative diseases
could be a defect of a splice variant or
splicing yeah and so that suggests that
a lot of the ones that have been around
for a long time like s.o.d and that
people are looking at that they should
actually look at the regions that are
affected first and then do RNA seek to
see what's happening yeah the question
is the cell type-specific so how
frequently you can figure out yeah sure
types of cell
forgetting to degenerate first so so you
figure you go back a couple of weeks or
something yeah sure but that also
requires that RNA seek become much less
expensive because if you have to look at
different ages different yeah sure and
it's a it's a real issue uh I don't know
if if China's looking into how it making
it more accessible for people without
giant budgets and things like that yes
so far the only a sick right now
everywhere I think globally is become
more and more nasty expensive and the
other is so those no input our music so
like a less than ten nanogram yeah yeah
yeah something like that will
dramatically improve our / / sick sick a
consequence what you're suggesting is
that you not only have to look at a
specific area but you have to look at a
specific age yeah specific at cell type
and yeah so so yeah sure um is it
possible this is sort of a leap from
from what you were talking about but i
was iva stimulated by the title of your
talk is it possible that the RNA
metabolism for complex you're talking
about quite a nerd degeneration and
quite a heterogeneous group of illnesses
with quite a different heterogeneous
cascade of effects is it possible that
some combination of the medication and
the cascade of events that companies are
neurogenetic a degenerative disorder
changes the RNA metabolism and so I
didn't get to your question so so what
what and sorry yeah we I'm not a
geneticist I'm should I call it a
psychologist I guess ah
so my questions I see your your study
was looking at whether or not the
metabolism of the RNA affects the neuro
degenerative process I've work with a
lot of people with neurodegenerative
disorders and I guess I find myself
wondering whether the I don't know very
much about RNA and metabolism but I'm
wondering if the metabolism is affected
by the Cascade of different events
including the treatment rather than just
the abnormalities in the RNA the genes
affecting the are RNA because most of
the neurodegenerative diseases I know
and I was I was part of a team that
looked at schizophrenia for a while no
one thinks about those kinds of
illnesses is due to single genetic n
puts but in fact a multiple number of n
inputs and also environmental factors so
I guess that's why I'm thinking about
the causes behind the the it's it's
complicated yeah so so one thing I think
we need to think about is their arm it
could be Marco target so like here yes
thousands of target affected and intron
often introduce the premature
termination codon and introduce some
like truncated form truncated protein so
that may also contribute to the disease
development so it's it's complicated so
at this moment we are not very sure the
disease so for the particular mute in
the YouTube so disease is caused by RNA
toxicity or protein toxicity they are
not very strong yeah as its moment but i
prefer is the RNA toxicity yeah thank
you
you